today a special day josh fleming a
left-hander from webster college becomes
their first alum to make his major
league debut a left-handed thrower
against kevin bisgio who digs into the
left-handed batters box the 2-2 pitch
swing and a miss he struck him out and
josh fleming
and his major league debut in his first
at bat
strikes out kevin biggio for out number
one welcome to the big news
that's a great way to start a career ken
thornton who began the year in the
injured list is making this appearance
with just two days rest why well he only
lasted two thirds of an inning on only
32 pitches against the phillies
so two men in scoring position with two
outs for satsuga thornton ready in his
25th pitch
hit on the ground out to second flag by
biggio easy toss to travis shaw on it
first
oscar hernandez travis shaw and lourdes
gorilla jr coming up four five and six
in the order
the 1-0 hernandez jumps on one and
drills it deep left field and long long
gone
to oscar hernandez wasting no time
he gives the rookie another first he
serves up his first long ball and
belongs to t oscar hernandez who adds to
his team leading home run total that's
number 10 for teo
one to nothing blue jays
and kay will make his seventh appearance
of the season he last pitched on
thursday through 22 pitches we told you
right before the blue jays at bat came
to an end trent thornton when reaching
for that right elbow the reason that he
landed on the injured list
two weeks ago
williams rolls forward
back into the wine the lefty throws
swing and a miss
randall grichik is going to lead off
this fourth inning
line shot and positioned perfectly up
the middle
wendell is there to grab that one that's
the first out in the fourth inning it'll
bring up vladimir guerrero jr
first pitch to vladi is swung on hit
high in the air deep right field giving
chase leaning diving and he can't make
the catches brandon low in right field
the ball hits up against the wall
vladi's taking off for third here comes
the throw the slide and it gets away
from the third baseman diaz but fleming
backing up nicely vladimir guerrero jr
just hit a triple the batter is travis
shaw getting a lot of work left on left
this season the 0-1 swung on hit on a
line up base it into left field over to
get it as meadows tay oscar will stop at
second into score is vladimir guerrero
jr and the
baton is passed to brandon drury
but behind two-and-oh he throws slow
chopper back to the mound he's got it
turns now throws to first in time and
just in time to get drury josh tobos
took too much time there but in the end
the blue jays leave the bases loaded he
allows just the one run defense swings
to the left for guerrero
now the 1-0 pitch here's the swing of
the grounder toward third yandy has it
spins sets his feet throws across in
time to take care of guerrero and that
will
retire the side that ball was hit hard
but yandy made a nice play and then
was able to gather everything in to
throw it across the diamond in time
jose martinez will pinch it for michael
perez
as borucki checks the runners no they go
and the pitch is swinging and looped on
the right field that's going to get down
for a base and it'll score a run wendell
around third he will score on his way
two-thirds of thomas he's going to get
the stop sign there and the rays
have cut the lead at 2-1
austin meadows against the lefty
he swings and sends a high fly ball into
right
hernandez sets up to make the catch and
the tag adamus is going to head to the
plate and he is safe the ball is loose
and martinez will move into second and
the raids have tied this game
brandon low at the plate
and he shoots it into center field
that's going to drop for a base hit and
here comes martinez grays take the lead
on the rbi single by brandon lau three
to two rays
runners on it first and third g-man choi
the batter
the 2-0
swinging a high fly ball in the air to
center richik drifting to his left he's
there to make the catch and finally the
inning comes to a close
and jansen's the batter he's over two
the 2-2 check swing did he go the appeal
down to first did not
three balls and two strikes on jansen
oh close
todd tishner has just ejected
kevin cash
three and two on jansen rudder takes off
from second pitch is down to the dirt
it's ball four on jansen and hernandez
gets his second stolen base of the
inning
rowdy is coming in wow and they're
leaving fairbanks in
now the infield not shifted but still
playing the pull in the pitch swing and
a miss he
struck him out the rays
get out of this sixth inning unscathed
and it's up to vlady two down in the
seventh and a runner at second the blue
jays are down three to two
they give guerrero the gap in left
center with karemae over towards right
center and the pitch slow ground ball by
the mount hits them out adamus cutting
behind second has it on the run throws
to first in time
and guerrero is retired it took all of
three pitches for castillo to retire
vlady with one out and one on ray's lead
by a run up steps austin meadows
here it is swing line drive base hit
right field the third base is kiermai
being waved home hernandez with the
throat of the plate not nearly in time
as meadows delivers
an rbi single on the rays lead at 4-2
4-2 rays looking to bust it open and
here comes g-mon choi
here it is swinging a high fly ball into
right pushing hernandez back towards the
warning track in right center he's under
it now makes the catch tagging at third
scoring easily as meadows lao takes
third base gmon cashes in another and
the rays have a 5-2 lead
here's yoshi with first and third
2-2 swung on and lifted in the air to
left center field giving chase gorielle
reaches out makes the catch in the gap
one out one on the batter is lourdes
curiel jr lourdes goriel smacks the
first pitch to deep left field back goes
meadows he turns he looks and it's gone
lourdes goriel puts it right off the
cutout
of a nice lady in the first row
it's his third home run of the season
and he's made it a one-run ball game the
blue jays trail the rays
five to four two outrunner at second and
that'll take mike cenino
one two swinging a miss he struck him
out
so the blue jays are down to their final
out and here's randall grichik the first
pitch breaking ball popped up this
should do it g-mon choi on the back rim
of the infield he's there he makes the
catch in the raise win